[Music]
[Applause]
Jim Nance joining us the Hall of Famer
he called the Steelers and the Eagles on
Sunday been a part of cbs's coverage of
March Madness since 1986 and he called
his first final four I believe in 1991.
next year's final four is in Houston Jim
went to Houston 40 years after Houston's
run to the National Title a little
symmetry there Jimmy all right I see
what you're doing there uh when's the
first time you thought about retiring
from March Madness it was actually it
was a while back great to be with you my
friend uh
I actually thought I might do it in 21
but that was a covid year where we
somehow the NCAA put together a an NCAA
tournament all in Indianapolis with just
sparse crowds they limited tickets and
it just didn't quite feel like the time
I wanted to do it and I knew Houston was
out there I wanted to be on nothing
against Turner they've been phenomenal
Partners but one year we'll call the
game on Turner and then the next year
it's on CBS and they all today I just
thought I should call my last basketball
game on CBS and there was Houston and by
the way you said uh 40 years since our
Championship we lost in the championship
to NC State as you know April the 4th
1983 I was in the stands as a fan and um
you know maybe just maybe I'm gonna go
out with Houston winning the
championship we're preseason number
three with Kelvin Sampson doing
remarkable things we got a great program
and would it be I mean for me it would
be unbelievable to be able to call a
Houston championship and take off the
headset yeah NC State and Jim Valvano
that couldn't happen now
what what NC State did against Houston
Cody because of the shot clock you know
that they you know Jim
Jim was able to strategize yeah the way
that they won um yeah yeah it was
different it wasn't a shot clock then
um
yeah I I think that
we see seeds like what state was they
were a nine seed to win it and you know
we had UConn a few years ago that won it
in a similar range
um in 2014 we see some miraculous runs
to the final four I mean it was an
incredible night I gotta tell you
one that you asked me one that I first
think about giving it up
and I'm so comfortable with it and
excited about it and blessed beyond
belief that I got to call it for this
many years it'll be 32 Championship
calls
behind that
and I'm it means probably nothing to
anybody I'm not sure it means anything
to me but when I took over for Brent who
I dearly respect and love and Dick
enberg had done it before Brent
and Gary Bender was in there too who I
respect but Brent and benberg called six
championships each
next April in Houston will be my 32nd so
I mean I I don't want to be greedy and
I've I've gone on for a long time and
I'm grateful for it it was time for
someone else to do it it was time for me
to be home more often and that was the
the real Central motivation for me was
to was to try to get back a little time
because I've had three events three
Sports a year that I've tried to manage
and it's been a lot of time away from my
kids and they need me
you've been able to call you know
obviously all the golf as well but if
you're looking at the the sport that is
going to give you a great story every
year
would it be March Madness or would it be
the Masters well it's pretty hard to
beat March Madness because there's so
many stories and everyone's involved
every corner of the country has some
sort of tie to a conference or a team
and uh it definitely it captures the
country's attention so I love it I'm
gonna miss it
um but the Masters to me is uh the thing
that is the deepest in my heart I mean
I've never chosen one sport as my
favorite event to do but I think
everyone knows that the the Masters is
uh is something I feel a real personal
tie to
um it was the one event that when I was
11 years old I turned to my mom and dad
and said that's what I like to do one
day I'd like to be one of those voices I
was watching a Masters tournament I want
to do that and
um I've been so fortunate that I I'm
still living that childhood dream even
into my 60s so it's uh it's been pretty
amazing you know how long I want to do
the Masters for that remains Central as
does the NFL for many many more years
with Tony we were going to do this
hopefully another decade or so or maybe
a little Beyond but the Masters I would
like to do it 51 times as bizarre as
that sounds because my 51st Masters
would be the 100th plane of the Masters
and I'd like to be there to see the end
of the first century and that that's
just a little goal that I have in the
back of my head I'm through 37 right now
so
14 to go hopefully did you just announce
your Master's retirement I did okay this
just is there you have it yeah yeah Jim
Nance in 14 years well that'll be it
thank you
yeah we did we we have a gym dance game
that Paulie wants to play all right uh
Paulie so just the question Jim we don't
know exactly where you grew up we did a
little bit of research I know you lived
in many different places but we're gonna
guess who is your favorite athlete when
you were like 10 11 12 years old I'm
gonna go first
I'm gonna say well wait he grew up in
Virginia New Orleans New Jersey Jersey
is that correct North Carolina Charlotte
North Carolina born yes you're right New
Orleans Moraga California Colts Neck New
Jersey we moved around my dad kept
getting moved up the corporate chain so
uh we saw a lot of different parts okay
Jim Nance's first favorite athlete
Paulie you go first I feel good about
this I'm gonna go Pete Maravich oh
that's a big one from my he was playing
at LSG when I was in New Orleans he's up
there high uh Seton I had the exact same
thought Pistol Pete get out I'm looking
at him right now to make sure that the
time frame matched up I swear okay
pretty I know Houston didn't come until
later so this is going to be a far field
but I'm gonna go Earl Campbell Marv you
got away yeah that's too late yeah I
love her yep Mark I'm gonna go with then
known as Lou alcinder oh oh
I'm gonna go with Archie Manning
wow I loved Archie Bill too I love that
man favorite athlete growing up Jim
Nance your first favorite athlete
Roger Staubach
you wouldn't have ever guessed that one
but I love Roger he knows that yeah I've
told him I've become a friend we've had
some meals together and uh great regard
but uh Julius Erving was a big favorite
of mine too as a kid who's playing for
the Nets when I was living in New Jersey
and I just love the the basketball and
the watching him play and uh the
gracious way treated people and of
course in golf I had Jack Arnie and Tom
weiskopf
I love Tom weiskopf it reminded me of my
dad he had this stature and his presence
about it was very Regal stood Straight
had his beautiful gorgeous golf swing he
just passed away a couple of months ago
and um
yeah I love Tom weiskop I'm going to do
a master's special on on Tom this year
so uh those are a few of my favorite
things as they say inside the music
yeah yeah a wiseconf great golf designer
and probably should have won more on on
tour but it's easy to say that but then
he's going against these the some of the
greatest golfers of all time like you
should have won more Tom you were more
talented or as talented well he should
be I know this isn't uh something that's
probably on everybody's hit list right
now but it's all mine he should be in
the World Golf Hall of Fame for all the
things that he did as a golfer who had
enough wins by today's standards to be
in the Hall of Fame what a major at
Troon in 73 coming up on the 50-year
anniversary and his golf architecture so
he saw and he's a broadcaster too by the
way so he saw the game through a lot of
different lenses and he was excellent at
everything that he did I'm I'm actually
going to be with Jack on Thursday and
Lanning Watkins and Tony Jacklin this
week because I'm going to tape a special
and talk to them about about Tom who I
actually was honored to be asked to
deliver as eulogy at his funeral so
um very fond of him you know it's weird
when you you have these Heroes and you
actually grow up Dan and this is I'm no
it's same for you if we get to know them
get to meet them you know you know so
you have that awkward I've got to get
past that stage of I'm that little boy
who looks up to him and now like they
know you who you are they know your name
you have their phone number and they're
your friends like I don't care how old
you are you're still a thrill to know
these people that you grew up idolizing
and that's in sports and it's also in
broadcasting for me I got to know all of
my heroes in broadcasting and um you
know you were talking about Normandy a
minute before I came on the air you're
like Jack Whitaker was on that that list
of you know for me of McKay and Sumrall
and enberg and Gowdy and shanko and
Jackson and all these guys You Know Jack
Whitaker
attended our wedding
which happened to be on the 68-year
anniversary of the day that he actually
stormed the beaches of Normandy he was
an American Hero he fought for this
country he was in the battles on the
shores of Normandy so um
yeah it's uh I don't care how old you
are uh the people that you look up to
and you try to model your life after
then you'll eventually get to meet them
it's one of the great gifts in life yeah
don't take it right now you're one of
those people
well I don't think of it that way at all
but I I think of me being someone who's
trying to represent them I will say that
I want to represent them well those
people that meant a lot to me and
inspired me I want to make them proud
well just put it that way that's that's
the best I can hope for great to talk to
you hope the kids are always always
thanks everything's well thank you my
friend and uh let's do it again soon we
appreciate you all we we hope to cross
paths it's always great to talk to you
Jim thank you buddy that's Jimmy Nance
gym Nance and uh been part of cbs's
coverage of March Madness since 1986